contando miley cyrus nomi da dare
fastidio a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo video sono vari j oggi siamo
tornati studia un fair platform che uno
dei giochi che giocava un tempo anche
voluto riportare sul canale dopo che
sono passati 26 anni mi chiama ricordo
ancora ma allora quanto ero malato lei
allora pretino conoscesse sta roba
questo gioco è la storia di una ragazza
senza faccia che ha dei capelli il
peggio dei miei che deve scalare e dei
degli ostacoli mi fai passare tutto
storia musica per cortesia mi dà
fastidio
benissimo vado giù bene questa è una
trappola
non è vero ma anche quella porca vacca
che anche qualora ne vincola dopo ancora
bene prossimo bene questo gioco ha delle
trappole all'interno ad esempio
il bello che lo sapevo anche che sarebbe
finita così ma me ne sono sbattuto le
falle ho detto vabbè dai facciamo lo
stesso niente proflex al check point e
hallelujah si frate va bene questo lo sa
ok vediamo non mi sta piacendo tanto sto
gioco è la cosa che non mi ricordo bene
e che un tempo c'era c'era anche
riuscito
non mi ricordo quante volte ci sono
volute non me lo ricordo quante volte vi
ci sono volute ma l'ho finito credo è ma
porca put vacca che anche prima solo
morto così so fare porca vacca lytham a
edizione porco schifo ma perché c'è
perché mi devi dare fastidio cristo
perché mi dà l'idea fastidio con i
blocchi invisibili è già un casino di
suo gioco non è che devo stare su quel
coso che scorrono racagni una bella se
non ci avesse i checkpoint sto gioco che
bella vita che farei
finalmente right click and select minuti
to turn of music a l'ho già fatto zio
tanto lo so che quel locale precisato lo
stesso
no veramente
all ci siamo di nuovo decente salto bene
yellow flag is the end of the level
hallelujah tonico io hallelujah stavolta
va quindi ci sono più livelli hanno
ricordato questo bene vai almeno di ma
lasciamo perdere
ha pure pure sono pure gli ascensori ma
ci mancava solo quello accessori in
orizzontale tra l'altro lo sapevo lo
sapevo non risultare vabbè lo sapevo
anche che sarebbe andata a finire così
non sapevo anche con il mio problema ma
per te cosa devo fare lì no cesima boys
ma voi siete fumati delle robe
pesantissime prima di programma sta roba
come dovrei fare come ho fatto prima per
l'amor di gesù vi prego datemi una mano
di mia tisana di qualcosa una camomilla
quello che io non ci voglio neanche mai
credere a questa cosa o ma come fa
non ci arrivo ci arrivo lì gesù è quello
di mezzo era una trappola è un convinto
ok questo non è non è una trappola
quindi quello dopo c'è la check point lì
però non ha neanche saltato perché mi
sono messo a rievocare i vecchi giochi
che ho fatto sul canale che avrei voluto
dimenticare come la mia prima di fare
youtube non ci arrivo ragazzi non ci
arrivo veramente ve lo giuro puntuta ion
la cortissima non ci arriva neanche
all'ultimo non ci arrivano noi non ci
arriva
non dite niente voi dovete stare zitti
non voglio vedere un commento qui sotto
non voglio vedere i disabili tuoi
commenti per questo video non ne voi non
voglio veramente crederci ed è ok aiuto
bisogna fare qua davvero va bene non so
quali ostacoli ho saltato alla fine ma
gli esaltati quindi perfetto che bounce
of enemy air seasiders jump salto del
suicidio beh carino poi saltare sopra la
testa di nemici va bene
sì però si gesù per sto vedendo
io no
ho tirato l'attestata leggendaria rai a
non ci possono neanche andare lassù
ok è molto a madre però raga qua devo
andare veramente neanche mi ricordo più
dove sono caduto devo andare proprio a
culo vuoi veramente a culo ero caduto
più grande ma ci sono le monete che
porco dai dai dai pian piano stiamo
facendo dai salta la salta sulla moneta
e mo che ne so io dove l'altra cosa
questa che culo ogni tre ma ogni due
atti o [ __ ] stavolta alla fine
madonna radio ciao azzeccato la terza mi
faceva cadere
la camminata nella fede
beh mi sono fidato a volte fidarsi è
bene non fidarsi e secchio mister weight
mister mister c'è una freccia che porca
vacca mi viene
mister peso lassù voi che puoi chiamarti
mista il peso premier per attivare le
leve va bene figuriamoci se mi viene in
mente di saltare quando schiaccio la
leva ai perfetto mista il peso
niente un casino ma non è così difficile
saltare c'è mio dio
ok ok non ridete siete delle persone
brutte o madonna come mi sono fidato
male come mi sono fidato male vai così
perfetto michele va bene mettere a due
frecce se capita è ma proprio se capita
per carità se mi impegno ce la facciamo
lo sentono sento lo sento che sto per
fare un fenomeno
porca vacca cielo riuscito
madonna madonna la donna madonna nuovo
donna next level e va bè cosa vedo
eh sì vabbè ci mancava solo la roccia
che era nota la volevo finito veramente
questo gioco perché veramente un casino
e acai porca vacca come è possibile
no
a
ok ok va bene va bene vai vai continua
continua ultima sbattitene bortoli non
so neanche non sappiamo neanche le
trappole che c'erano le ho fatte senza
geni un fenomeno un grande 118
e va beh sì ciao 4 ma poi perché mi deve
arrivare sempre a tanto così per poi
morire come la devi far pesare al
massimo
oh che bello non sapevo né howard non ci
avrei mai sperato è figura soltanto
l'avevo fatto bene avere tanto ok a non
devo toccare niente proprio ok
madonna ragazzi veramente felicità
eterna guarda guarda non è tanto la
felicità interna della felicità eterna
sarebbe finita questo gioco però mi
rendo conto che non è richiesta un po
difficile
sto saltando a caso completamente a caso
l'unica roba buona di questo gioco che
effettivamente non mi posso lamentare
che la chi dice che poi ci sono ci sono
dei giochi dovesse mori adesso gli inizi
da capo proprio all'inizio del video non
mi ricordo più a caso a caso rango park
fucka c'ero non capisco cosa devo fare
gli scusami ateo ma arriva ad un punto
dove sono nel vuoto cosa devo fare
parlami cosa cosa mai dovrei fare lì
scusa mi ero dimenticato di saltare cosa
come come dovrei ri cosa questa devo
fare qua tua madre morta putrefatta cosa
devo cliccare cosa devo schiacciare dove
devo andare parlami cosa vuoi
ma cosa vuoi non mi ha toccato ne ho
rotto già una tastiera con getting over
it questa è la mia seconda solo più
questa pasta
basta
la gamma come nichi è possibile se io
sono allibito ve lo giuro
cosa devo fare qua
madonna
ecco quasi mica devo in testa va bene va
bene ce l'ho fatta ho vinto finito di
and thanks for plaining stampatore morta
o più di ring e tu med
no per carità mi è piaciuto tanto va
bene basta la capa st
io farei e bull il coccodrillo che è
scattato per avere sia piaciuto ragazzi
era quello che era da e ho tentato di
riesumare un video un gioco vecchio
uscito mille anni fa
mannaggia a me però è semplice mi piace
come te mi piace che prestigio come si
sa se non sai come si scrive the e noi
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video da
ragazzi